on a demandé à dr karl weiss de venir
nous éclairer dr weiss bonsoir oui
ça va très bien et vous oui l'été va
bien bon ben on a quand même on a eu un
bon été
bon très bien troisième dose dr weiss
hier le ministre la santé me disait on
attendait une recommandation est ce que
dans votre esprit c'est inévitable on
s'en va vers une recommandation pour une
troisième dose pour tout le monde même
ici
alors un troisième dose est inévitable
pour d abord des groupes ciblés c'est à
dire que quand on regarde ce passe dans
le monde au niveau de la science là on
sait que les gens de plus de 60 ans qui
ont été vaccinés il ya déjà plus de cinq
six mois qu'ils ont eu leur dose ont une
certaine perte de leur humour immunité
donc il ya des pays qui ont commencé à
d'administrer des troisième dose à des
sous groupes particuliers et là on ne
parle pas encore de toute la population
générale on ne parle pas de donner une
troisième dose à l'ensemble des
doses à des gens qu'ils ont c'est à
cause de l'orage de maladies sous
jacentes ont un système immunitaire
affaibli et ces gens là sont donc une
certaine perte de leur immunité pour de
protection et c'est dans ce contexte là
qu'on parle de troisième dose en sachant
que la vaccination maintenant a fait ses
preuves pour prévenir la maladie sévère
pour prévenir les hospitalisations pour
prévenir des séjours en soins intensifs
et aussi pour prévenir des décès disons
c'est là où c'est surtout important
parce que c'est là où on veut préserver
notre système de santé et ne pas revivre
ce qu'on a vécu au cours des vagues
précédentes mais pour la gr public vous
ne voyez pas ça comme étant une
nécessité à court terme
ce ne sera probablement pas une
nécessité pour l'instant à court terme
ce qui risque d'arriver par fonte est ce
qu'il faut souligner c'est que sur la
planète est à peu près seulement 10% de
la population mondiale qui a reçu ces
deux doses de vaccin donc on l'a vu au
québec au québec on contrôle bien je
vous dirais la pandémie on la contrôle
bien au canada et même aux états unis
bien sûr il y avait des débats et des
zones un peu plus chaud mais globalement
pour s'aperçoit que là on est revenu à
une vie beaucoup plus ouverte de ce
qu'on était auparavant et sans la
vaccination nous n'aurions jamais été
capable de faire cela donc le fait qu'on
a pu voyager emmené au québec allez au
restaurant recevoir des amis voir sa
famille etc on a eu des la coupe stanley
avec des milieux de personnes dans les
rues de montréal et on n'a pas eu
d'impact majeur en terme de société sur
le nombre de cas parce qu'on est arrivé
à immuniser un grand nombre de personnes
maintenant comme à l'échelle planétaire
il n'y a pas forcément beaucoup de gens
qui sont immunisés et ben ça va faire
perdurer la vie de lakovic 19 dans le
monde pour un bout de temps donc ça se
peut que dans deux ans peut-être dans un
an et demi on commence à parler de dose
de rappel à des ans une jeune fille en
santé présent on pense beaucoup d'abord
et avant tout aux personnes plus âgées
et aux personnes à vis du question avant
de vous laisser vaccination obligatoire
pour le personnel de la santé le nouveau
brunswick qui entre dans le bal
aujourd'hui l'ontario hier le québec que
hier est ce que pour vous c'est ça va de
soi
ben oui ça va de soi c'est une question
d'éthique jeu ça devient une wii ça
devient vous savez une question
d'éthique normale est attendu je pense
qu'on parle pas de vaccination
universelle et obliger tout le monde à
se faire vacciner on parle de gens sont
des travailleurs de la santé qui sont
censés protéger les autres vous vous
rappelez que la première vague les
malheureusement les gens qui sont
décédés au québec dans les chsct on aura
amené le virus on leur a apporté le
virus et donc c'est des gens qui ont été
infectés par des gens qui sont entrés
dans leur dans leur environnement donc
aujourd'hui à cette époque là on n'avait
pas de bac sort aujourd'hui on a un
vaccin ce serait non éthique je vous
dirai pour des gens qui s'occupent de
personnes à risque de personnes
affaiblies ne pas leur donner leur
maximum de protection très bien dr weiss
le
déjà vaccinées doublement vaccinés qui
se sont retrouvés quand même à l'hôpital
on a vu il y en a il y en a plein nez y
en a qu'est-ce que vous ça vous dit sur
l'efficacité des deux est ce que ça vous
aimez un dos tout au contraire vous êtes
c'est normal qu'ils en est malgré tout
c'est tout à fait normal on est malgré
tout vous avez vu que les vaccins des
débuts personne a dit que c'était 100%
efficace par les études ont parlé d'
efficacité de 90 à 95% on sait par
contre que non seulement l'efficacité 20
noeuds ça dépend quel groupe d'âge vous
regardez si vous regardez les moins de
60 ans qui sont totalement vaccinés qui
n'ont pas de problèmes de santé ces gens
là vont quasiment à l'hôpital et ces
chiffres se répète dans tous les pays du
monde non si vous regardez les plus de
60 ans qui ont des problèmes de santé ou
quand des facteurs de risque même le
fait de le fait d'être vaccinées ne leur
donne pas une protection absolue mais
réduit le risque d'être hospitalisée
réduit leur risque d'être d'être
sévèrement malades un souper ou même de
décéder d'un facteur varie selon les
études de guiche juste à 25 bon alors
c'est quand même important
malheureusement il ya aussi des gens
qu'on hospitalise il faut savoir pour
des raisons autres que l'aco vide mais
qui teste positif pour la copie je vous
donne un exemple vous avez été vaccinées
deux fois vous êtes un enfant tu sauves
accès en vous un spécialiste pour
infarctus mais vous avez été en contact
avec un cas trop vite et vous testé
positif vous n'êtes pas forcément les
malades de la ligue hospitalisée mais
elle est quand même hospitalisé avec
l'aco vit très bien dr weiss toujours un
plaisir merci on se reparle on va devant
se reparler plusieurs fois merci
beaucoup de plaisir toi et bonne soirée